back it wouldn't be a five Christmas Eve
special unless you were here and you are
thank goodness well and if we didn't
have toys we sent Jesse Juan and Greg to
the world famous FAO Schwartz to check
out some of the hottest holiday
selections and what's the worst that
could happen that's why now
[Music]
what do we do here in testing I think
we're gonna play with some toys right
yeah this is the typical cliched
Christmas segment every show does are
you gonna be difficult this is where the
show sends you to a toy store to play
with toys that other shows have already
played and what happened then well New
York they say
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
request can you make one disappear and
you think Jesse's the points in the palm
of your hand the lid on top make a nice
tight fist for me okay watch closely the
money jumps all the way from your hand
through the yet no way you know he has
very small hands this is a robot that
dispenses candy biggest Hershey bar you
ever saw there's one over here another
robots
it's a gluco tron - you've changed you
gorgeous
- penny another robot they're everywhere
they're coming to take our jobs it's
only a matter of time America
[Music]
the name of the bear is doodoo just so
you know it's very strange
[Music]
Merry Christmas to all and to all a good
night
Lou Dobbs another priceless cameo from
mr. Dobbs he makes everything a little
better so you guys you thought it's
gonna be horrible and they have that
giant unicorn and I saw you it was
downhill from there by the way you know
what's interesting what I learned is
it's good to be short because when we
walk into the toy store the people who
don't like Jessie can see Jessie because
he's tall but the people who don't like
me or you they can't see us oh you
weren't there no like the river when you
walked in and somebody said somebody go
hey Jessie in the wave and then somebody
else have come up and like threatened
you and dropped the f-bomb rummaging
through people's pockets yeah being a
little man that I am I can see why
didn't you mount that unicorn I told you
to get on up there heck oh I thought you
meant man just put it on the wall a lot
I mean it's pretty expensive store that
for you Dana yeah I wouldn't spend that
they got you three of them I can't wait
for our Secret Santa what are you
working forward to getting on Christmas
tomorrow a no gift packed oh I kind of
violated it because I've sent to Peter a
link to a backpack purse that I wanted
Oh backpack first you don't look like
somebody who would wear a backpack purse
yes I do
you broke a contract I going to jail for
five years in answer to your question
you know it's kind of unbelievably got
to dance like they did in big on that
piano right that was pretty cool you had
some moves well I say Greg that wasn't
into it no no in fact they edited out
the part the thing that I did on the
piano I brought it down to a really low
level it was nice that they allowed us
in yes that was you know what because
it's jam-packed
it's not the old fao schwarz it's a new
one yeah there's a lot of course being
TV anchors we got to cut in line
everybody in line was so happy to see us
what are they doing like the illegals
you know Greg they cut right in front of
everybody
where's due process that's right we need
a process we need a process maybe you
should just give them all $800 unicorns
and they'll make everything better
that's right problem solved